[MUSIC]
>> So it's great to have
Ajay Divakaran and Yi Yao
from SRI in Princeton, New Jersey.
Ajay will give a talk on, I guess,
some of the recent work they've
been doing with the U-Dub and
some other universities
on vision and language.
So Ajay is the Head of
Vision and Learning at SRI.
He did his PhD at RPI.
Then, he went to, I
think that was in the days
of the startup business,
so he did his wavelet
compression stuff,
went to a startup, and
then got disillusioned,
and then went to MERL in Cambridge.
Then, he came to SRI in 2008,
and since then, he's been there.
I remember Ajay was
the first one at SRI
to start a completely new thread
on human understanding,
what we call human understanding
in HoloLens and here.
I still remember that
US had just gone in,
not just, but for a few years,
they had been in Iraq, US Army.
One of the biggest problems
they used to face is,
they knew how to fight,
they didn't know how to
deal with civilians.
That was the major problem in Iraq.
So DARPA started a project
called Good Strangers,
how can you train people to be
good strangers in a strange land.
So Ajay was the first one who went in
this concept to DARPA and said,
"You know, we'll mount
Kinects and other sensors,
and we'll have a feedback loop,
where there is some scenarios
being played in
virtual reality and people
start interacting."
That became a hit, really.
He built a system with Kinects
and other kinds of sensors,
and people would get trained
in being good strangers.
I think since then, he's continued.
Yi also has worked on many,
many things, both at SRI,
and she used to be at GE.
Great to have you here.
So Ajay Divakaran.
>> Thank you. Thank you very
much for that kind introduction.
I should point out that
Harpreet hired me into SRI,
and he was my Direct Supervisor
there for a very long time.
So I'll start off by first talking
just a little bit about
SRI and in particular,
the Center For Vision Technologies.
Then, I will cover some of our work
on applications of
joint multi-modal embeddings.
Then, I'll hand it over to Yi,
who will describe to
you some of our work on
using a graph-based
modeling of activity.
So SRI is a non-profit
research institute.
The business model is
contract research.
The clients are primarily government,
but a reasonable number
of private clients or
commercial clients also,
the model being that
you incubate the technology
with government funding,
and then over time, transition
it to commercial activity.
I guess these statistics
are interesting,
in the sense that about half of
the company consists of people
who have at least a master's.
So it's definitely a bit of
a PhD-heavy organization.
But you see that
the other half is not,
which means that there is
an emphasis on development or
advanced prototypes rather
than just pure research.
These are all the startups
that have come out.
The most famous one, I guess,
is Siri on the iPhone.
So now, we're in the Information
and Computing Sciences division.
It has four labs,
and you can say it's a sort of
a microcosm of SRI at large,
very similar composition
of skills, and so forth.
I'll jump directly to the Center
For Vision Technologies.
So one big claim to fame we have
is that the 10-yard line
in football was developed.
So this Harpreet has himself
presented this slide many times,
so it feels strange
showing it to you folks.
We have about 80-plus people.
This number might be off.
I think it's gone back up now,
it's some 86 or some, yeah.
So now, here are some examples.
So one is the GPS-denied navigation
activity, augmented reality.
Then, at the bottom
right is the human behavior
modeling that Harpreet
was referring to.
So it started off with that project,
and it has now been parlayed into
the driver behavior modeling
for Toyota's concept car.
So it will be featured at the 2020
Olympics as part of Toyota's.
Then, on the left there,
we do typical video retrieval,
which to this crowd,
I don't have to explain.
This is another way of
looking at the technologies.
So there are some technologies
under Intelligent Mobile Platforms,
human understanding,
human interaction,
and then multi-modal data
analytics and machine learning.
What's happening is that in
the process of developing
these technologies,
we are also developing certain core
machine learning techniques.
Offline, I'll be happy to
engage with you on those.
So this is the org chart, let's see.
So there are four managers
here who report to me.
So Mohamed Amer does some,
I'll just give you
some sample projects,
so he does joint computer
human storytelling
under a DARPA program.
So that's why he likes
to call it Creative AI.
Amer works on the human
behavior understanding,
in which he is working on
both driver behavior and also on
human-computer dialog management.
He works on multi-modal analytics,
both of ground imagery as
well as overhead imagery.
We work for government
clients over at
imagery's an important part
of what we do.
Nick is a systems person.
Now, what I will do is just play,
since we mentioned the,
what's happening? No.
>> [inaudible] ?
>> No. The video over here where,
I'll just show
these couple of videos.
So this is the driver
behavior console,
and so I just wanted to give
you a framework of how.
So the main challenge in this
kind of problem really is
the tremendous lighting variation
that the auto environment offers you.
That's the absolute
biggest challenge, right?
Because the variation
is just immense,
and so Amer has
developed pretty strong.
I mean what we have
is way beyond this
but it's not ready
for public release,
and then on the other side of
this is the full body behavior,
which is what we developed in
that project that [inaudible]
was referring to,
which is we're looking at
facial expressions, gaze,
posture gestures and
also speech tone.
So we do some amount of audio also in
this lab and you will see
later we do some text,
and then we are also interested
in interaction between individuals.
So for example, on the left we are
looked at children
doing pair programming.
On the right, people playing
a tower game together.
So this was all done.
That stuff was published at the
Learning and Knowledge Conference.
This was published at
either CV for example.
So in addition to the real-time
work that I showed you,
this part of the talk zeros in on
our social media analytics work.
So this is something I do with
my young colleague current Sika.
This is like of those four groups,
this is yet another group,
basically just the two of us.
So are interested in
social media analytics from
the government side comes
from detecting people
who are trying to
recruit for extremist causes,
and so we look for extremist content,
extremist behavior and so forth.
That's why the government
is interested,
and the key is that
these platforms have
two things that make
them really stand out.
One is the sheer volume,
and the other is the complete
lack of constraints,
meaning that people can put
whatever content they like.
People will even may
put a day's worth of
Fitbit data on social media,
anything goes right.
So it's truly
multi-modal, truly vast,
and so what it does
is that it stretches
the boundaries of whatever
standard problems you want to solve.
You're going to solve a much
more magnified version
of that problem.
So that is the way of
motivation and platforms that
were looked at include
Twitter, Instagram.
They are put Facebook
over there but no,
we don't have access to Facebook but
surprisingly YouTube
functions as a social medium.
The next time you go to YouTube,
just keep this observation in mind.
Now the problem that
we were interested in
was modeling content reaction.
So given a piece of content,
who would be interested in it,
and given a group of users,
what kind of content would
they be interested in?
We were interested in
this problem because,
if you are trying to
track extremist activity,
when you see extremist content,
you should know which
group is going to be
triggered by this kind
of content right.
So that now obviously on the
commercial side it has an application
to advertising and so
forth, but for now.
So more on the technical side,
then what we are
interested in is taking
the modalities of text and images,
and then projecting them into
a common multimodal
semantic embedding space.
So basically you can say this is
a multimodal generalization of
embedding such as word2vec.
You can just see that
that's pretty much
almost exactly what's
happening there.
That you have paired data,
and the pairing is what is important,
so now why we are interested in
applying it to social media,
is that this is a highly
unsupervised kind of technique.
So in social media that is good,
because getting labeled
social media data
is basically not possible,
and social media has
inherent pairing.
So those are two things
that encourage us to.
So now there are
some research questions
associated with
multi-modal embedding.
So you have seen work I'm
sure on zeros short learning,
on captioning, visual
question answering,
learning better, Word
embeddings and so forth.
So now, our interest in this came
from the social media analytics.
So we were interested in first of all
seeing if we could push Zero short
learning in a new direction,
and we are also interested
in finding out if you could
embed the users and
the content in the same space,
to treat users as
an additional modality,
and then have a three-way embedding,
so that I could have
seamless retrieval between
all of those modalities.
So that led us to
first this problem called
Zero short object detection.
So this is something we
published it easy CV 2018.
This came out of a project that we
started as a summer intern under
the darpa metaphor project,
and what we're interested in here is,
the not merely object classification.
We want to also localize the object,
and it should be previously unseen.
So I'll just flip through
these in the interest of time.
This is just some
background material right,
that when you want to.
This is basically saying that,
there are these existing
techniques like YOLO,
Faster, R-CNN, SSD etc.
But scaling beyond
a few added objects and
detecting completely new objects
is still beyond the reach of
these kinds of techniques.
So now, what is Zero short learning?
I'm going to state the obvious just
so at least we have
a common terminology.
So, the idea is that,
you learn from seen classes but
then you predict on unseen classes.
So that is the you can say
a good definition of
what Zero short classification.
So then the question is,
what is Zero shot detection?
So this illustration is
telling you what that is.
Detection is that in
addition to saying
that there is a cat in the picture,
you're also saying
exactly where the cat
is or exactly where the dog is right,
and now you're going to do
this in a Zero shot fashion.
Now all the other problems
such as the occlusion,
viewpoint, lateral etc,
still come in play.
There are some certainly
obvious applications
like robotics and surveillance.
The question is, do we
really need thousands or
training examples to deal
with a new category?
Our answer based on what
we've looked at, is no.
So this is just a sketch of
our approach to this problem.
So first of all
we want to take previous work
in zeros short learning.
You don't want to create
something out of whole cloth.
But then the task is,
how do we model the background.
So what happens is that,
when you have all only
previously seen objects,
then the definition of
background become very clear.
Because it is whatever is
not in the class of seen
objects is the background.
The moment you have objects
that you've never seen before,
now there's a new class.
So there is the typical background,
which you could call a
stuff class like sky or
a wall or water etc.
But now you have a class
of objects that you have
not seen before and that may
also merge into the background.
So that presents
a bit of a challenge,
and you will now see how we
have dealt with this kind of
problem as we go forward,
and then what we've
also done is that,
you know you'll never have
enough training data,
that is for sure, for
any problem of this nature,
just because it is so big in scale.
So what we have done is
explored this business of dense
sampling of the semantic space.
So wherever you are certain,
what you do is that you try to
sample close to that and make.
So even though you don't
have labeled data,
but you try to sample over
there and try to make
the embedding very
dense around that
particular location.
So now, what is our baseline method?
We use is R-CNN architecture but
that's really not the point.
I mean, you could use
any other architecture also
for this kind of method,
and we are just showing you some sort
of you can say, already some result.
Well, what we've done
is we've carried
out training on the scene classes,
and then when we test
on the unseen classes.
So shoulder and skirt were part
of the set of unseen classes,
and you see that this
actually does in fact
detect the skirt and the shoulder,
presumably because in
the world embeddings,
there was enough similarity
scene between say skirt and
shirt or proximity between short
and shoulder and so forth,
and then there are
some joint learning
of the visual attributes as well,
which managed to give
you this kind of result.
>> So I guess the idea is that,
in this embedding space,
all these concepts will be
nearest neighbors
versus other concepts.
>> That's right. So
the idea is that when
you're train this embeddings,
what you are trying to do is,
you're trying to pull similar things
together and you're trying to
pull dissimilar things apart.
So you are depending very
heavily on the pairing.
If it did not have paired data
and embedding would not work.
>> What is the testing scenario
like in object detection?
It's basically forming
boxes being embedded.
In this case will you say
testing on unseen classes?
Is it exactly the same?
>> Yeah.
>> They're bonding boxes
and they're being labeled.
>> That's right. There are
bonding boxes and they
are being labeled,
and then you say that okay,
I was able to see that
there is this skirt there,
even though it was not part of.
I didn't train on skirts.
Now on the lighter side,
at another place where
I gave this talk,
a young lady in the audience
pointed out that
this not a skirt that's a dress.
So what I always say is,
that's a reflection on
the gender composition of
the people who made this algorithm.
>> The sizes of the bounding box are
basically whatever
these networks generate.
>> Yes. That's right.
>> So they are both backup words
and back up boxes right,
so there is no structural information
embedded into the system right now.
So what would prevent, let's say,
shoulder getting
detected as skirt and
vice versa because there
is a lot of similarity?
It's [inaudible].
>> No, that is very true.
So with these deep learning systems,
you can come only so close
to giving some kind of
an intuitive answer after
the fact I could try
to tell you that somehow,
this fabric need to be a bit floppy.
Overall, the nature of
the relationship between fabric and
skin with lower body attire is
different from upper body attire.
So if you have enough
of training data,
that kind of thing will be learned.
>> [inaudible].
>> But having said that,
I'm not telling you that that
is the answer to the question.
It's an educated guess,
I would say, frankly.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. So that's the general idea.
Now, here are
some mathematical details
here that what you're doing is,
you first trained
the embedding in advance,
and now, you are projecting it
using the linear projection.
Then, what you are asking me,
you are taking the box and then
comparing it to the label.
So basically, it's a box
by box result, as it were.
Then, what you are doing is,
you are pushing embedding for
similar boxes and class labels,
you're trying to ram them
together, and so forth.
So now, the interesting
part comes in,
which is one of the innovations
in this approach,
which is what allowed
the solution to the problem.
So what detection models
with a fixed number of
classes do is that they will
add an additional background class.
That's like some kind of
container class that just
takes care of whatever is
not in the same classes.
This is not like that.
So when we try to just use
a single background class,
we end up not getting very good
results in certain cases.
The reason for that is that
these previously unseen objects
merge into the background.
So they get classified as background,
and they are not seen at all.
So what we have done
basically is come up with
a way that assigns latent classes.
So it allows latent
classes to emerge,
these are not labeled.
But what you do is, you
make a distinction between
background areas that are
just stuff and background areas
that actually correspond
to some latent classes
that may or may not correspond
to previously unseen objects.
So once you do this kind of a thing,
we find that we are, in fact,
able to get better results.
Now, in the densely embedded space,
what we're doing is,
the issue is that this embedding
space can be very sparse,
you have no control over the density.
We all know that any kind of
interpolation method will
work well if it is being
done in a dense region,
you want the points to be dense.
So what we have done
over here is basically,
we augmented the training dataset
with just additional classes.
There is no overlap with
the unseen classes,
we do our best to not cheat.
But then, what you are
trying to do basically is,
you are trying to take
whatever areas you know
and you want to pack
them with more data so that
those areas become denser.
So now, what we have done is that we
have worked with the MSCOCO
and Visual Genome dataset.
Now, we did this split,
where, with MSCOCO,
we had total of 65,
so 48 seen and 17 unseen.
Visual Genome has more classes in it,
and we see an immediate
consequence of this.
Now, these are some more details,
but I think in the interest of time,
I can skip some of these details.
But the idea basically is
that this is, you can say,
our experimental framework, this is
the framework that we're
using to run these tests.
So what happens is that
for the Visual Genome,
having this kind of procedure
where you are letting
these latent classes emerge in
the background actually helps,
and you get the best results.
That is not quite evident
in the MSCOCO case,
and that is our theory is that
that is because in Visual Genome,
you have a larger number of objects.
Presumably, when you
have a larger number
of objects to present
a greater challenge,
and that is when some benefit
is seen for this kind of
method of having a latent
background classes, and so forth.
So here is some more now.
There are some good classes,
and there are some bad classes.
These are, obviously,
you-all agree with
me that mistakes are
more interesting than
what you get right.
So when you look at this,
so you see, for example,
over here that it gets zebra wrong.
Later on, you will see it
persistently called zebra some.
It just somehow does
not recognize zebras,
whereas you saw that it's able
to detect things like skirts,
and buildings, and
cakes, chairs, so forth.
So, yeah, this is little more detail,
but I'll skip ahead to
some visual results.
So most of these results
are as expected.
For example, this result
is fairly obvious,
you know it is picking up a bus.
My favorite result is this one,
I made a double-take with this one.
I first thought it was a dog myself,
but it's actually a cat,
but this system thinks it's a dog.
Hongjiang Zhang used
to be with Microsoft,
and he once told me that when
your system makes a mistake,
you feel that, okay,
it's real, it's not.
So this is a fascinating mistake,
in the sense that I think that it's
the pointy ears that somehow
this thing is learning,
and it thinks that it's a dog.
But for the most part,
it's not bad at all,
it's actually getting
a lot of these things.
Now, here, you see [inaudible].
You had this question, right?
Look, it made exactly that mistake.
See? Do you think that it's a skirt?
It saw the fabric and skin boundary,
and it thinks it's
a skirt, but it's not.
So it does get those things
wrong probably because
the thing that you pointed out,
there is no structural
information captured.
Now, it persistently thinks that
it has found cattle over here.
At some level, this is reassuring.
In fact, later on,
you will see we have tried
some metrics where what
I encourage my folks to think
about was that maybe you think of
an ontology and try to look for
similarity one level above.
So probably mistaking
zebra for cattle is not as
bad as mistaking zebra
for a door knob.
That's a much more serious mistake.
So there are levels at
which you can test how
well this kind of
technique is working.
>> All those categories were
not there in the training data.
>> No.
>> None of them were. Were
there any cases where they were
overlapping in the two datasets,
but somehow, the domain would
be very different, right?
Let's say, the cat's.
>> To my knowledge, no.
>> No?
>> To my knowledge, not,
but I'd have to go
back and check that.
>> If you would allow a few labels,
will the [inaudible] as a second one?
>> If I allow a few,
>> Few labels.
>> Right. So that's
a very good question.
I have wrestled with
that all the time
I worked with machine learning.
What I've found is that
it's hard to say I mean,
he did try, current tried
some talk and type experiments.
So we did get some results
like that back there.
>> But it's also possible that
what your calling unseen concepts,
>> Yes.
>> What you're saying unseen
is in the visual domain,
but they're there in
text domain, right?
>> No, absolutely.
>> Yeah.
>> So they are not unread.
They are unseen, but
they're not unread.
>> So zebra might not have
been there much at all,
in either one of them in which case.
>> In which case, it goes
of course like this.
It's still fascinating that it's
somehow thought it was cattle.
But again, I won't read
too much into that.
Who knows what it latched on to,
we don't necessarily know.
This actually gives us the cue
to ask another question,
so how do we judge
the success of an embedding?
Because that's our next problem here.
Because we start off with
this multi-modal embeddings
for social media now.
The reason we are interested
in an embedding is that we
want to solve the problem I
mentioned earlier which is that,
given a piece of content,
who would be interested
in this content?
Given a user, what kind of
content would they be interested?
We're interested in
solving that problem.
So yes, we can certainly if
we had a joint embedding,
that would be very nice.
Now, why are we interested in
this kind of thing specifically?
There's another reason also
like I was telling you earlier.
There is absolutely
no constraint in social media.
Absolutely, anything can pop up.
So you need to deal with that.
So it's a much harsher
environment than
relatively domesticated environments
such as MS COCO or VGG.
So that's what we are
interested in over here.
So we come up with this kind
of embedding technique where
what we're doing is we're
using images posted by the user
as a stand-in for the user.
So we really are not, obviously,
you have to take some user attribute
and use that as a stand-in
for the embedding.
You don't literally embed the user.
So in this case, what
we're doing is we're just
taking the images that
the user has posted,
and then embedding those.
So we're using the same framework
as we did earlier,
but now we are attaching
this user label with that image so
that we're maintaining it
as a separate modality.
So now, I'll play you
a video of this demo.
So now, what this allows you to do
is carry out a four-way retrieval.
So we have text, we have users,
we have images, and
then we have also done
some unsupervised
clustering of the users.
So we have user clusters also.
Again, what we do is that we use
an image as a stand-in
for the user cluster,
and we are able to embed user
clusters also in the same framework.
So what this allows
you to do therefore,
is that you can
retrieve based on text,
you can retrieve
the other three modalities.
So what are the type over there I
can't read, the thing too small.
Yeah, it says Amazon Rain Forest.
So you'll get some images
related to that,
you get the users who are
interested in that kind
of topic, and so forth.
Then you can go all over the place.
I'll play you that video in a moment.
So there are some details here on
this slide on how the embedding,
what kind of metrics are
being used, and so forth.
Now, what we are done here
is we have taken one month
of Twitter data,
and we wanted all
this to unsupervised.
So what we did was, we collected
one month of Twitter data,
and we took the top few hashtags.
So we just chose some
arbitrary numbers if we want,
because we wanted
some density to that data.
There's a hashtag with just one entry
that's going to come
in and just sit there.
So we got that.
So we ended up with
about 10-12 million tweets,
about a million images,
and 40,000 users.
These are month's worth of data.
It's surprising what this kind of
thing actually ends up learning.
Now, this is where we carry
out the kind of experiments
that you are talking about,
where what we do is we use ranking.
We tried to figure out whether
the rank makes sense or not,
and just a sanity check.
So we first test only with
text, only with images,
or only with users,
and we find where at least
much better than random.
Then as we start adding modalities,
as you start pairing them up,
you see that the rank
starts to improve.
Then, here are some results
with other variations.
This is in general, it's a bit of
an interesting problem
that exactly how
do you evaluate an embedding?
How do you believe in embedding,
how do you know what we
will learn, and all that.
So our operational
definition is that,
if for our task it gives
results that makes sense,
then we believe this embedding.
We have a restricted definition
of the efficacy of the- Now,
you see that we have played around
with different kinds of things.
You can use it with GloVe,
which is pre-trained on a very
large corpus or you can limit it.
Because there are some interesting
aspects on the tech side also.
The interesting aspects are,
that the kind of language you see in
social media is very
different from what you see
in the formal document
that things like
GloVe and Word2Vec
have been trained on.
So lots of informal language,
lots of these so-called
stopper words.
So you have to do some cleaning
processing and all that.
So there is that on
that side of things.
So here, there are
some more detailed results
where the joint model,
are you using a GRU instead of
a convolutional network,
and so forth.
The user clusters that
I showed you what we
do is that, those are unsupervised.
But we find that interestingly,
these clusters are
actually seem to make
some sort of semantic sense.
For example, this seems to
be around British politics,
this box over here.
The other ones we
have put some images,
so you see soccer images and
soccer related themes are sort of
falling together, and so forth.
So basically,
what we are doing right now is we
are trying to write all this up.
Then, the ECC part of course,
is done now with this part
with the social media.
We are waiting for the right
kind of forum to publish this.
What I'll do is,
I will quickly play you a video.
Then, I'll hand over to
you to talk to you about.
So I already told
you about this data.
This is one month of
Twitter data and so forth.
Now, see he types in over there,
he'll type in the box.
He types in say, "vegan food".
So when he types in vegan
food with the embedding,
he gets these retrieval.
So it's interesting
that one month of Twitter
seems to have images
related to vegan food.
>> So these embeddings
have used labels
associated with images when
the embeddings are created?
>> Yeah, basically captions.
>> Captions.
>> Yeah. Captions
sometimes, it's loose also,
if there are no caption but there is
a some kind of text
associated with that tweet.
That's the difficulty
with this kind of data.
But now you see that it is
doing retrieval from
all over the place.
Retrieval starting on the image side,
a retrieval against
starting on the text side,
but also from the user side
or the user cluster side.
So we are done this kind of
work where we are interested
only in rabble-rousing video.
We've published that at ICMI,
but this is a generalization
of that work.
Now you have a general content model
which allows you to predict
given a piece of content,
who would be interested in it.
So what I'll do is that,
I will pause over here
and I can certainly take a couple
of questions and let me,
>> Are they surprising results
in this which you expect?
They're plausible.
>> Though surprisingly
those are kind of topics that popup.
For example, we typed in fashion
not quite knowing what to expect
and we're very surprised,
you type in some designer
or something.
The breadth of topics is
a big surprise with this.
Because there is no way for
us to actually prove that.
There is no easy way for us to probe.
So I'll hand it over to
she'll tell you about.
>> Next, I will switch the gear
a little bit talking about
some of the video
analysis work we have done.
So this is also included
to the multimedia because
video is one source
of the data format.
So in here we just use action
segmentation as our task.
This is a slide to show that
action segmentation needs to be done
at different granularity levels.
To segment long videos,
we need to do inference over
long temporal span in order
to include the dependencies,
causalities and also some temporal
ordering of the actions.
At the same time,
we need to provide
a sufficient of details to
differentiate two similar actions
even at very short temporal span.
So to support these two requirements,
actually we started to work on
this graph based representation.
So we call it the Activity
Object Attribute graph.
So basically it has two levels.
On the top, we have the,
we call it Activity graph.
So it traces multiple
threats of activities.
So this level we can
do inference over
long temporal span to
include causality,
dependencies and
ordering of the actions.
On the bottom level,
we have the object attribute graph.
This where we have
detailed information about
the objects associated
with the activity
or action as well as their
attributes status or status changes.
So with this level,
with this amount of
detailed information,
we can differentiate
two similar actions.
Also, in our Object Attributes
graph as I mentioned,
we also check the status change
of the objects or even the actor.
In this way, we can not only infer
the explicit observations but
also implicit consequences.
So this is important for
some applications where
the observations are noisy,
we have missed detections or
even sometimes we don't have
the observation at all because of
the now overlapping
camera field of view.
So this is a high level
illustration of our framework.
On the bottom we have
the input image of frames.
Then we extract all kinds of
descriptors including objects,
attributes, actors, actions, motions
and also sometimes we include
the seeing descriptors.
Then based on this
spatial temporal graph,
then we apply what we called
the Stacked Spatial Temporal
Graph Collusional Network.
I will give you more details later,
but our network has
three major improvements.
The first we allow arbitrary
temporal connections,
so that we can account
for large amount
of graph deformation and
also as I mentioned,
we will use all kinds of
descriptors, objects,
actions, things to deal
with complex activities.
So we need a method to
support features or
support nodes with
different feature length.
>> Excuse me. What do
your nodes represent?
>> So I think here we have
different kinds of nodes.
You will see we have object nodes
here and also actor nodes.
Actually, our implementation we also
include the C-nodes and motion nodes.
So these nodes it's not,
it can't be like actors
specific though we will have
all kinds of nodes do describe
different aspect of the actions.
So it's not like we
are dividing the nodes
per actor, but we will have-
>> You know there's
no connection, right? It's not,
table or chair.
>> Yeah that's object nodes.
So for actions you will
have object nodes.
So if we go back here.
On the top we have the this
is the activity nodes.
So these are the actions.
But under for each activities,
we will have the actors
as well as the objects.
So actually our implementation
we also add a scene.
So all kinds of descriptors.
So these nodes can be like a bunch of
collection of the information
that is carried in the frame.
>> And the edges?
>> The edges, we have
two types of edges.
So as you can see the solid edges
here we call it the spatial edges.
So this is just connect,
some of the edges connect
the activities to the object.
This will specify the role of
the object in the activities.
So the dashed edges we call
it the temporal edges.
So this is connected across frame.
So we also, because in
the surveillance scenarios
sometimes the cameras will not
have overlap to field views,
so the red ones is still
the temporal connections,
but that is sometimes we may
have missed detections or
even don't have continuous observation
of the object or the actor.
So these are the edges for the graph.
>> You have a bunch of algorithm that
extracts for you-all those, right?
>> Yes. in the experiment,
I will show you what algorithms
we use to extract all
the descriptors of the nodes.
Then back to this,
on top of that we use
this hour glass structure to
improve the generalization,
performance, localization
accuracy and
also be able to handle the spatial
temporal at different scales.
So I will have slides for
these three improvements
in the following slides.
>> Excuse me. What
does the arrow mean?
So from the image,
some features are
going to get computed-
>> Yes
>> -and something is going
to get updated at the nodes?
>> Yes.
>> What gets updated?
>> So the feature describing
the nodes will be updated.
>> So each node is a vector,
real value vector?
>> Yes, each node is
represented by a vector.
>> So these nodes are basically
like random variables?
Like they're basically,
this whole thing is kind of
a graphical model, right?
>> Yes we use these graphical model
so that we can do
longer-term inference,
but as well as the graph carries
the sufficient and detailed
information of
the object's attributes
so that we can
differentiate similar actions
at short temporal span as well.
So, yes, this is
a graph representation.
So actually maybe should
make it clear that we do use
some algorithm so to extract
descriptors from the frames,
then we construct the graph.
Then we use some graph
convolutional network on top of
this graph to do
the action segmentation.
So it's not like end-to-end just
use one giant neural network.
So we use some neural
network to extract
the descriptors then construct
the graph then to the graph
convolutional on top of that.
So this is just some
background information
about graph convolutional networks.
So actually idea comes
from the spatial temporal.
>> So in a graph
convolutional network,
the convolutions are operating
on the vertices and the edges, both?
>> No. For the original
implementation
of the graph convolutional network,
is only under nodes,
so it only propagate based
on connection of the edges.
But the later implementation they do
consider the edges can
have features as well.
You can propagate
the nodes descriptors
as well as the edge descriptors
but for our implementation,
we use the original implementation.
>> Then from one layer
to another layer,
the graph topology doesn't change?
>> Yeah, that's the limitation of
the original graph
convolution network.
So here we still follow
the graph needs to be fixed
is not a dynamic graph.
>> Okay.
>> The dimesionality of
each feature is the same.
>> No.
>> No?
>> I'm sorry. So in here it is,
but in our implementation because
we use all kinds of descriptors,
we cannot allow that.
So we actually generalize
the computation
so that we can handle nodes
with different feature nodes.
I will come to that point later.
>> Well, it's just in
the convolutional graphs node.
>> Yeah. Actually yeah,
the edge actually is
the matrix of the features.
That's why you do need
the features for the nodes
to have the same length.
But I will show some work around
to solve the problem
where the nodes have features
of different length.
So for the original Spatio-Temporal
Graph Convolutional Network,
it is used for the scanning
based action recognition.
So again, there are
two major limitations.
So in the original implementation for
the temporal connection is actually
degenerates to the great
like data structure.
It only allows the connection of
the same joint cross
consecutive temporal frames.
So that's why there are
spatio-temporal convolution equation.
We only see the
spatio-adjacency matrix,
but the temporal adjacency matrix
degenerated and also the features.
As you mentioned, the features
they use fixed length.
So actually the feature itself
is very simple only the x,
y location of the joint as well as
the confidence from I
believe is open post.
I'll put. So with
these two limitations,
the original Spatio-Temporal Graph
Convolutional Network cannot handle
the complexity of
our graph representation.
So again, back to
the first improvement,
and we want to use arbitrary temporal
connections so that we allow
different graph convolution
including newly detected objects,
mix the detectors including
objects and activities.
So basically, we have
two layers of the graph
convolution that blue one
is the spatial graph convolution
and the green one is
the temporal graph convolution.
By adding the temporal
adjacency matrix,
we can handle the connections in
the temporal access with
different graph deformations here.
So for features with very less
actually we designed two solutions.
On the left-hand side,
this is a very straightforward
implementation.
So we just add shallow layer of
the network to map the features
of different lengths
to the same lengths.
So this is very
intuitive implantation.
But on the right-hand
side and this is
the implementation will later
use to undershirts dataset.
Actually we because the nodes itself,
some of them knows actually
may have the same length.
So we group those nodes together.
Then map them to a one spatial
graph convolutional network.
So that's why we have several
spatial graph convolutional network.
The output from the spatial
graph convolutional network
we'll have the same length.
Then we can put them to
one Spatio-Temporal Graph
Convolutional Network. But-
>> So the edges between
one object and another object
between one object and
an actor are they all based on
spatio sort of nearness or part
of the graph gets set up between-
>> Yes. So for multiple objects,
we build the object to activity
based on the closeness,
the proximity of
the object and activities.
So but here, I think we do have
problem because when we group
the nodes with the same list
together then put them into
one Spatio-Graph
Convolutional Network,
we did not consider
the connection across group.
Actually, we put that connection,
model that connection in
the Temporal-Graph
Convolution Network because
our Temporal-Graph
Convolutional Network
can handle arbitrary connections.
So this is the design
tricks behind it.
>> Yes that's what sounds
really weird because
these edges they are very
important for your final result.
So I would expect your method
to optimize them somehow.
The connections between actors and
just really find the action, right?
>> So actually, when we
construct the representation,
we consider that which
nodes should be connected.
So that is the current
implementation. I agree.
We can be more dynamic about
how to construct the edges.
So actually, run now,
we are working on some
attention mechanism.
So yeah, so that we can,
we just do not connected
or not connected,
we assign some attention so
that we have some dynamics.
Yes I agree that this
is a very good point.
For this implementation,
we do not have that.
But we are working on improvement
to have the edges more dynamic.
>> So intuitively, what
you are currently doing,
you're trying to find correlations
between these graphs temporarily,
that's what you are
currently doing you
assume that your graph edition is
correct and you are just trying
to correlate between the structures.
>> Yes. It's kind of
because if we just use
one network to do that,
we'll go into higher,
higher level or where you go
into like longer 10-plus,
you lose the details of
each individual actions.
So in this way, we kind of
can't do the inference.
As you said, just getting
the correlation like
frame-by-frame longer-term
but the graph itself at
the spatial connection.
It also carries the details
for the actions that
is the improvement we see here.
>> Your hand might
modulating your audio,
your hand movement, you might
want to clip to the mike.
>> Sorry. Okay. So some pros
and cons for the naive
implementation.
Again, when we map the features to
a common and less or common space,
we may lose information,
but the network
architecture is simple.
When we use the more advanced ones,
we reserve the information we need,
but the design is more complex.
Than the third implement we have
is the Hourglass Architecture.
So we borrow the idea for
the Hourglass Architecture
you only used for
the convolutional layers.
So but we do have
some like careful architectural
design I want to point out.
First for these applications,
since we want to do
the action segmentation.
So we only need the segmentation
at the temporal access.
So that's why when
we do the encoding,
we have the feature
pulling on the graph.
But when we do the deconvolution,
we do not blow up to
the original graph dimension.
We only care about
the temporal resolution,
and also when we do the convolution
and the deconvolution,
we also need to adjust the
spatio-temporal adjacency matrix,
the dimension of
those matrix accordingly.
Okay some results.
So we test this network
on two datasets.
So one is the CAD120 this
may not be that famous,
but we choose this
since this dataset.
They give us some
precomputed features so that
we have fair comparison
with other methods,
and the second one we use to share.
Oh yeah. As you ask these are
the networks we used to compute
the descriptors for
the spatio-temporal graph,
our charades datasets.
So for the CAD120,
we compare with
the state for the act.
We were able to achieve about for
improvements in the F1 score,
and also for charades,
when we use the VGG as
our backbone network,
our performance is at
the state-of-the-art.
Where we use our 3D we're
comparable to the state-of-the-art,
but a little bit lower
than the best number.
But the best the number
actually they already
used the attention mechanism which
we are working on it right now.
So with the introduction of
attention or more dynamic graph,
we believe our numbers
can be pushed further.
So I will just show some
of the ablation studies.
The first obvious wise
to compare with just use
the features without
any graph architecture.
We can see 4.06 improvement in
the mean average precision.
We also want to see whether
the hour glass structure does
improve the performance.
Actually, we seed about 2.5
improvement in the map.
So actually, we also want to
see because I pointed out
the limitation from
the original Spatio-Temporal
Graph Convolutional Network.
We try to implement
Vanilla version of that.
But since the original algorithms
applied to a scaling to
data we don't have
the complete replica here.
But we do just degenerate
our temporal connection to adjust to
the same nodes across one time step,
and also we just use
one type of feature.
For auto note, we do not use our
glass and we see 5.4 improvement,
and next I had
some ablation study with
different types of input features.
Here we use one type of feature to
type then up to four
types of features.
We can see they gradually
improve the performance.
We also tested our network with
different temporal connections.
Because one of the improvement
is to generalize
the network so that it can handle
arbitrary temporal connections.
So actually from our experiments
with different architecture
the optimal number of
temporal connections as
well as the improvement.
It introduced can vary.
So our conclusion for
the time being is
that the we do see improvement.
But how to optimize the number of
temporal connections that is
application architecture dependent.
I think with that,
I just showed some example results.
This is the result from CAD120 for
actions segmentation
and charades dataset.
So for charades, as you can
see the ground truth is
not only the action but also
actually some objects here.
So I will stop here for
any additional questions.
>> So you're measuring the MMP,
you're measuring the IUU of
the detected box in time?
>> Yes
>> So you have visualizations in
this box because the predictions
was the coloring pixel right for it?
>> Yes. For this segmentation,
the action segmentation means
the segmentation at
the temporal span,
not at the spatial.
>> Okay, but can you focalize
the particular motion in
some spatial location in the image?
>> For the current network, no.
It's just the localization
in the temporal access.
So it's not the spatial
semantic segmentation.
It's action segmentation
in the temporal access.
>> But you have
particular features that [inaudible]
into this type of action, right?
>> Yes.
>> These features have locations?
>> Yes, you are right.
Actually, with the object,
we can localize, but I should
say that for this experiment,
we can localize, but for
action segmentation task itself,
it does not require
the spatial localization.
So it only requires
the temporal localization.
So when we do those map,
so the IoU is also added tIoU,
that's the IoU along
the temporal span,
not to the spatial locations.
>> So even with these datasets,
the mAP numbers are relatively
low in general, right?
>> Yeah. For sure, it is.
>> So do you think that an
evolutionary approach will increase
the performance just by
adding to these networks
or something completely new is
required to go to the next jump?
>> So actually, this is
our motivation to use
graph convolution network,
because we think the end-to-end
maybe is not the solution.
We do need some structural data.
You use those end-to-end to get
features, the structure inference.
So that's our motivation here.
But again, as I said,
this is just the first
implementation.
We want to introduce
more complex graph,
that is adding the dynamics
with the tension.
We also need to add
the different edge features.
So for now, the edge is just saying
these two nodes connect or not.
We believe with
all these actual information,
this can guide us to
a better performance with
this graph structure.
Yeah. That's our motivation here.
>> So when you populate
the graph structure,
what happens if you make
a mistake in populating this?
So for instance, you are
saying that this person
is interacting with
these two objects,
for instance, right now right?
What happens if
that early thing is wrong,
then the graph you
constructed wrong in turn?
>> Yeah. For the time
being, the spatial ones,
we do not have any correction.
But with the attention,
we can allow more connections
to the network to
attend to the specific edges
that contribute to
the final decision.
But for the temporal ones,
we already allow
some redundant connections.
Again, we need the tension
to make it more dynamic.
>> That's the beauty of
end-to-end learning, right?
It helps you avoid this sin
of early commitment.
>> Yes.
>> That if you're committing
to some interactions,
could you learn
these structures also?
>> For this one, we want to have
some structure in the inference.
Otherwise, at that semantic level,
we think you need those structures
instead of a black box,
let you choose anything you can.
But I agree, how to
make the transition
between the end-to-end
learning to how the network,
kind of from the black box to
the structured data, the interface,
how do you allow some capability
to correct early errors?
We agree, that's also some research
direction we can look into.
>> [inaudible] graph structure
learning has ever worked before?
Because I remember Daphne Koller
used to work a lot on
that in the early 2010, 2011.
That's a harder problem than this,
it's better to learn the potentials,
the [inaudible] potentials.
>> I'm sorry, Miss. As Maria was
pointing out, that ultimately,
if your goal is to figure
out what is responsible
for a certain action,
which objects, which
particular hand movements,
it seems that if you have explicitly
literalistic nodes which can
ultimately tell you that,
then somehow, you need to
represent that explicitly, right?
>> Also, end-to-end typically
requires way more data,
and they think that the last CVPR,
this paper was about
how you can combine
different tasks to
solve [inaudible] task,
and this combination typically
reduces the amount of data
that you need for it.
I think it came from [inaudible] It
actually makes sense to separate,
but it also makes us to
take care of errors.
If you have very high
correlated errors,
then you are screwed right?
>> Yes.
>> If you have some outliers,
then probably, your attention model
can figure it out.
>> I also have a question actually,
we were having a discussion.
So couldn't you do
everything you did here with
the CRF on top of [inaudible]
What is really the difference?
I understand CRF so
I'm trying to really
understand conceptually what is used.
So the CRF could be,
again, the carefully connected graph,
all the nodes you have in the graph
could be the nodes of the CRF,
and it would have
this pair-wise potential.
>> Yes. Actually, I will say,
a couple of years ago,
Ali Pahadi, he is almost, I will say,
one of the first couple of papers
tried to use the features
from the deep networks,
then use the graph
representation to provide
some structure for complex
or the action segmentation.
Obviously, based on all this kind
of development of
the graph convolutional network,
I will say it's more powerful,
it learns more inference
capability from the data.
So I agree, yeah,
we did not do a comparison
with the original paper.
Yes, these are all the deep
learning-based methods, I will say,
but I believe some paper
did do comparison with
the original deep feature plus
CRF kind of implementation.
The performance,
the graph convolutional network
outperforms those methods.
>> Also, there's this
[inaudible] challenge, right?
One of the challenges there
is to localize actions.
>> You mean spatial?
>> Yeah, like in [inaudible] , right?
>> Yeah.
>> So I thought that in that one,
people have better results.
>> Yeah. That one has
better than the [inaudible]
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. We pick up this [inaudible]
because in the annotation,
they have some annotation
of the objects.
>> Okay.
>> Those kind of, but for
the [inaudible] they don't.
>> Okay.
>> What is the I3D plus
super events here?
What is super events?
>> So this is what they called,
I cannot remember what
the super events mean,
but I3D is a 3D
convolutional network.
>> Sure, yeah.
>> I think they do some hierarchical
structure of the events,
so that's why they call
it the super events,
but they also do some attention.
>> Make super pixels. [inaudible]
>> We could [inaudible].
>> Okay. That's true.
>> Actually it's interesting to
mention that that type of thing.
So the other work I showed
you where [inaudible] there
actually we had a generated network
at the bottom and then
a CRF at the top,
in fact, trying to combine
this discriminative
and generative in one package, right?
But our algorithm is
like two part pattern to
whatever [inaudible] part
also that, first of all,
the distinction between
the reasoning part
and the standard part also
is slowly getting blurred.
There's nothing, and
this structures also are
much more power than [inaudible]
>> The graph convolution networks
are also [inaudible] feet forward.
There's no optimization and inference
[inaudible] In the sense
that graphical models,
you have to do [inaudible] problem
to find the answer to some problem.
Here, there is
no optimization, right?
>> Yeah. It's kind of just
fully [inaudible] the training.
>> Yeah.
Everything is just
directly regressed.
>> Yeah, yes.
>> Make it even more obscure.
>> So [inaudible]
your observation is,
you do something with data,
you do something with
[inaudible] and you add
either a graph convolution network
or you will add a CRF to it,
and you get two percent
point improvement.
>> That's right.
>> Yeah.
>> In a sense, evolution
doesn't seem to help here,
you have to have a revolution.
>> For [inaudible] CRFs,
we'll have to solve
some argument problem,
and I guess here, [inaudible]
>> Yeah. There's
no optimization at runtime.
>> Just create computation,
right? [inaudible]
>> Yeah, you can put it that way,
the optimization is starting
the training process, right?
You learn.
>> Yeah.
>> Great.
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> Thanks a lot. Yes.